[Musique]
il ne me reste plus beaucoup de temps à
vivre
amman il y une chose dans ce monde que
tu dois savoir tutoie savoir faire une
bonne fée vous trouvez pas ça étonnant
france où viennent jamais précisément de
leurs vacances
avec qui tu vas te dépuceler dabou ce
que tu veux dire sa dernière volonté de
génie ça serait depuis la nuit des temps
si dans la bible
[Applaudissements]
on pourrait rentrer regarder la télé
cette ville je crois que je ferais bien
de rentrer aujourd'hui je vous rencontre
le coeur triste lors des week-ends nous
a quittés vendredi
[Musique]
pardon je m'appelle big jay je crois pas
au coup de foudre milla ce genre de
choses mais je suis persuadé qu'on peut
rencontrer quelqu'un et savoir
instantanément
cette personne contrat pour non je
voulais qu'on passe du temps ensemble je
voudrais bien lien l'église genia là bas
mon vieux mas d'état et j'ai
l'impression d'avoir été lavé tous mes
péchés si quelqu'un découvre pour 2010
palet passe quelque chose rare je
voulais qu'ils s'arriment
c'est ta grand mère
qui te manipule depuis l'au delà ta
grand mère vient de mourir que ça donne
le droit de se comporter comme une
[ __ ] à l'église de toute cette
histoire ceux qui croient s'aimer dit
est complètement dingue
on a été triste chamboulé mais quand on
en tirera le bilan comprendra plus
toutes les erreurs ont fait seront
probablement de très bonnes erreur
n'avait plus rien à perdre je ressentais
la présence de dothy à l'écouté il
m'encourageait tu peux aller chez ml si
tu veux non pourquoi elle est privée
sortie est ben moi maintenant je
comprends pourquoi tu tu ne t'en aller à
l'église
[Musique]